parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro l'école
maternelle petit prince à magny les
hameaux vient de voir son enseignement
du développement durable reconnu par
l'éducation nationale
nous avons rencontré l'équipe
pédagogique la fabrication d'un
téléphone portable a bien plus d'impact
sur notre environnement que nous pouvons
le penser
nous y sommes intéressés la santé des
abeilles et des insectes pollinisateurs
sauvages est au coeur d'un plan national
d'action du ministère de l'écologie pour
en parler nous sommes ici à l'opie
office pour les insectes et leur
environnement avec serge gadoue bonjour
bonjour vous êtes chargé de projet
pollinisateurs sauvages à l'opie mais
tout d'abord que sont ces pollinisateurs
les insectes pollinisateurs sauvages
ce sont les abeilles que tout le monde
connaît d'autres hyménoptères qui sont
des insectes proche des abeilles les
guêpes pour
faire simple les papillons de jour mais
aussi de nuit des mouches en particulier
les syrphes et puis quelques coléoptères
chez nous qui joue un rôle moindre que
dans d'autres régions du globe
pouvez-vous me faire un panorama de la
santé actuelle de ces insectes
le déclin des insectes prédateurs
sauvages les syrphes les abeilles les
guêpes a été évalué en europe
de l'ouest plusieurs parties nord la
france n'est pas comprises dans l'étude
mais on peut penser qu'il s'agit de même
effet chez nous puisque c'était pays bas
allemagne grande bretagne et belgique
les abeilles les papillons son déclin
bien-être savons c'est bien documenté en
a sans doute des effets contrastés au
sein des syrphes puisqu'on a des espèces
qui sont par exemple liés aux pucerons
et d'autres qui sont liées par exemple
aux oies mort donc avec d écologie qui
sont très différentes et donc peut-être
des dépressions différentes sur ces
groupes d'insectes
quelles sont les raisons alors de leur
déclin les raisons du déclin c'est
pratique principalement la fragmentation
qui résultera de l'occupation du sol
donc urbanisation les pratiques
culturales
quand on a de grandes monocultures sur
de grandes surfaces donc on a peu de
milieux naturels ou semi naturels qui
restent près présents et ceux qui sont
présents centre et déconnectés les uns
des autres il ya de trop grandes
distances
on a en tête donc l'abeille domestique
qui peut faire plusieurs kilomètres pour
aller chercher donc de la nourriture
pour les petites abeilles c'est un rayon
d'environ 200 de 150 à 250 mètres autour
du lieu où elles sont nées donc c'est
très faible
on a aussi des problèmes liés à des
produits de la chimie de synthèse qui
sont utilisés en agriculture ou dans les
jardins par les particuliers
et maintenant on commence à voir aussi
apparaître les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique
ces insectes sont très important vous
pouvez m'expliquer pourquoi les
accusateurs sont très importants pour la
nature parce qu ils politisent 60 à 70 à
80% des espèces végétales sauvages et
parce qu'elle participe aussi de la
pollinisation d'un nombre très important
de nos cultures
donc si aujourd'hui on a des fruits des
légumes dans nos assiettes et pas
simplement des céréales c'est grâce aux
abeilles et autres insectes
pollinisateurs sauvages
le ministère de l'écologie a présenté le
20 mai un plan national d'action qui
s'appelle france terre de pollinisateurs
ce plan lopy a fortement contribué
pouvez vous nous présenter le plan
national d'action en faveur des insectes
pollinisateurs sauvages donc vis comme
tout les plans d'action de ce mystère à
mettre en oeuvre différentes actions
pour sauvegarder ces espèces
là en l'occurrence il s'agit d'un plan
avec une entrée fonctionnel qui concerne
tout un groupe d'espèces classiquement
on a des actions qui visent à améliorer
la connaissance puisque pour protéger il
faut développer d'abord connaître donc
mieux évaluer le déclin savoir quelles
espèces en particulier sont le plus en
déclin
améliorer la connaissance donc pour
pouvoir établir par exemple des liste
rouge des espèces menacées en france une
partie qui vise en fait tout ce qui est
pédagogique communication donc pour que
tout le monde sache qu'il ya ce pena et
puis le dernier volet concerne en fait
des actions concrètes à mettre en oeuvre
notamment par exemple par les
agriculteurs
par les espaces les gestionnaires des
espaces protégés ou gérer en faveur de
la biodiversité de façon à ce qu'ils
aient concrètement des pistes d'actions
à mettre en oeuvre sur leur territoire
sont pas des professionnels mais en tant
que simple citoyen y at il des gestes à
adopter tout citoyen peut agir pour les
abeilles sauvages les papillons etc
donc il ya différents documents qu'ils
sont en ligne sur internet via le
ministère de l'écologie sur site de
l'opi d'autres sites sur le programme
urban biz notamment on peut disséminer
des petits nichoirs dans son jardin si
on a un jardin
on peut aussi donc améliorer la
ressources florales
ce qui est très important pour les
abeilles pour les abeilles qui disent
longtemps comme les bourdons plusieurs
mois donc il faut qu'on a une offre en
fleurs qui commence depuis le début du
printemps donc ça peut être dès février
dans le sud mars chez nous jusque fin
septembre voire plus loin si l'automne
favorable laissé les coins de son jardin
avec une flore spontanée et sauvage se
développer et enfin avoir besoin aussi
de terre pour aménager l'intérieur donc
qu'est de l'interview qu'ils soient à
disposition pour ces abeilles
merci c'est un gars doux pour cet
éclairage oui le 10 juin l'école
maternelle petit prince à magny les
hameaux est devenu le premier
établissement yvelinois être labellisé
le 3d ce label valorise l'engagement du
corps enseignant autour du développement
durable
reportage réalisé avec patrick jacques
de dixmude les trois enseignantes de
l'école maternelle petit prince viennent
tout juste de recevoir le label 3d de la
part de l'éducation nationale le 3d
c'est pour l'école en démarche de
développement durable
l'école manie quad est actuellement au
deuxième niveau sur les trois que compte
le label
le deuxième niveau c'est un niveau
d'approfondissement ou en fait on
mobilise l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative où les élèves commencent à
construire vraiment et dans leur
parcours d'élèves du début à la fin du
passage dans l'école
quand on est dans une école primaire du
cp jusqu'au cm2 des compétences liées à
l'éducation développement durable
combien les petits arrosoirs et
apprendra s'est passé à l'école
maternelle petit prince
cette année on travaille autour des
jardins potagers avec la mairie de magny
les hameaux la maison de l'environnement
et les associations ville verte et sky
en transition l'équipe pédagogique
poursuit l'enseignement du développement
durable on a fait dans l'école trois
années durant on a travaillé sur l'eau
avec les enfants avec différents thèmes
il ya eu le cycle de l'eau il y a eu des
abus la biodiversité et il y a eu le
patrimoine
on a beaucoup parlé de la préciosité de
l'eau avec les enfants comprendre
pourquoi une plante pousse ses besoins
savoir la reconnaître
les élèves ont participé des sorties
autour de ce thème
ils ont notamment visité une école
d'horticulture et le potager du roi
les 91 enfants de l'école de la petite à
la grande section aussi plantes et
fruits et légumes en mars et il ne les
arrose pas avec n'importe quel os loin
elle vient d'où quels appuis pourquoi tu
l'as rome les plantes est ce que c'est
parce qu'elles ont besoin d'eau pour
rebondir
moi ce que je trouve très important
maternelle mais d'une façon générale
c'est d'arriver à à à partir de quelque
chose de concret parce que ça prend du
sens en fête pour les enfants et tout de
suite ce qu'on va apprendre
ils vont comprendre pourquoi on
l'apprend l'enseignement du
développement durable s'inscrit aussi
dans l'apprentissage scolaire de ses
élèves pour reconnaître les légumes du
potager des écrits qu'on sont préparés
les plus petits ont collé des photos les
grandes sections qui rentre en cp à la
rentrée prochaine
écrivez nous inquiète pas l'éteindre pas
dire ça donne un intérêt à l'écriture
les décrire recopier des mots sans aucun
sens là au moins ils écrivent des mois
où il met du sang sur ce qu'ils aient
crise est importante
le label 3d a été mis en place par
l'éducation nationale en 2013 pour
l'obtenir les établissements doivent
solliciter leurs académies les élèves du
petit prince
eux vont continuer à oeuvrer pour la
planète qui a bien besoin qu'on prenne
soin d'elle à la fin du mois de mars 80
millions de cartes sim était en service
en france 25% des téléphones portables
seront jetés sans être valorisée mais le
cycle de vie d'un mobile à plusieurs
impacts sur la planète environnemental
mais aussi humain elodie moines pour les
images il est devenu incontournable le
téléphone portable batterie écran carte
sim coque
ce sont les éléments que nous
connaissons de nos mobiles mais savez
vous de quoi ils sont faits et a de l'or
dans les télés fournier du col d'agnes
à de l'aluminium il ya du plastique du
pétrole voilà plein de métaux différents
et puis aussi les conditions dans
lesquelles on va aller le chercher
par exemple les mines de coltan sondés
même dans laquelle il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui travaillent dans de très
mauvaises conditions en 2008 l' agence
de l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie l'ademe réalise une analyse du
cycle de vie d'un téléphone portable
moyen un téléphone consomment autant
d'énergie qu'un avion sur 57 km et
génère autant de gaz à effet de serre
qu'une voiture essence sur 85 km au
début du mois de juin la maison de
l'environnement accompagné
d'associations a voulu sensibiliser les
plus jeunes
alors je vous demande de créer un ou
deux projets à bas dans lequel vous
devez améliorer les choses mais pour le
moment on va retirer le problème
d'argent
je sais qu'il est là mais on va le
retirer pour que vous soyez plus
créatifs et réfléchir à l'avenir aux
prochains téléphones portables cette
classe de 5e est mise à contribution
et sinon servir un peu moins souvent ça
fait qu il s'usera moins vite et que je
pourrai garder plus longtemps vous le
téléphone ce départ semble à fabriquer
c'était très sale voyager un peu partout
les matériaux français même pas qu'il y
avait de l'or dans le téléphone la
solution toute faite elle n'existe pas
le projet serait de ne pas acheter le
gsm est de louer un peu comme quand on
loue une voiture donc l'entretien du
téléphone
même l'énergie pour être prises en
charge par le producteur le fabricant
dans sa synthèse de 2008 l'ademe
préconise d'éviter d'acheter un portable
avec un grand écran de ne pas laisser
son chargeur branché lorsque la charge
et complète ou encore de privilégier le
dépôt d'un téléphone dans une
déchetterie pour être valorisées
équilibre touche à sa fin mais avant de
nous quitter je vous propose quelques
rendez vous la ville de la verrière soit
développé un projet de jardin partagé si
vous ne possédez pas de carré vert mais
que vous rêvez de cultiver
n'hésitez pas à vous faire connaître
auprès du service concerné le jeudi 25
juin la communauté d'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en partenariat
avec la cci versailles organise un
colloque autour des plans de déplacement
inter entreprises
cp des yeux vise notamment à limiter la
pollution atmosphérique mais aussi à
favoriser les déplacements des salariés
jusqu'au 28 juin c'est la quatrième
édition de paroles de jardinier si vous
vous posez des questions sur la gestion
de l'eau à l'échelle d'une ville
l'office de tourisme de saint quentin en
yvelines vous propose de venir allait
lui poser le samedi 27 juin
voilà équilibre se terminer je vous
donne rendez vous le mois prochain
d'ici là pensent à faire un geste pour
l'environnement